Pet Sematary is the latest Stephen King
adaptation to get a theatrical release
although this is actually the second
time this book has been adapted the
original film came out in 1989 and I
want to apologize that over the past
week I haven't had any new reviews I
missed Dumbo but I missed that because
my wife and I went on a vacation that
we've been planning since the beginning
of the year for years I have promised my
wife I would take her to Disney World
and a year would go by and it didn't
happen I know that year would go by it
didn't happen and I began to feel really
guilty and so this year I was like we're
doing it and we went to Disney World we
had a great time rode tons of rides it
was awesome but now I'm back so let's
talk about some new releases Pet
Sematary follows a family that moves
from Boston to the backwoods of Maine
and when the father discovers a
mysterious animal graveyard in the back
of their house very strange happenings
begin to occur and supernatural stuff
because it's Stephen King and you
probably knew that because trailers
spoil a lot of things I never loved the
original film I didn't see it when I was
a kid I saw it when I was older and I
remember thinking it's not really that
scary I just what's the big deal like if
you saw it when you were younger I can
understand you being like really
traumatized by that movie but it never
really had much of an impact on me I
always thought it was one of his lesser
adaptations and so I was hoping that
with this new revamped version today
they could make it better than that
original and and really just capture the
the terrifying spirit of the novel major
pros right off the bat the acting Jason
Clark is great as this doctor who's
moved here experiencing things he
doesn't understand
it's questioning his belief system
because he mentions that he has a hard
time believing in God or the afterlife
and so when certain things start to
occur this is very challenging for him
amy seimetz as the mother is probably my
favorite performance in this movie I
thought she was magnificent she has a
lot to her character more so than the
father she has a past that you can kind
of latch on to and it's very terrifying
and you can understand where she comes
from her background why she's so
traumatized by things in her past that's
a character in the movie that I feel
could have been given a lot more
development because the father in the
film just isn't very can
pelling his character doesn't have a
backstory that you can really relate to
the kids in the movie though especially
the daughter really great work good
performances the movie has some
suspenseful scenes and some sequences
that I felt tense while watching and
overall I will say the movie is just
fine it's okay and a lot of it has to do
with the fact that the story only gets
as interesting as it does about halfway
through I won't ruin it for you if you
don't know what the plots about I won't
spoil anything but it takes a lot of
setup to explain what the Pet Sematary
is what it can do the results of what it
can do and then other things occur and
it takes half of a movie to get to the
point where you feel like something
really awesome is happening that first
half of the movie is loaded and I mean
chock-full of exposition so much
explaining characters just talking about
their lives their history just saying it
without actually seeing it or
experiencing much of it
there are some flashbacks that let you
in on things that occurred but for the
most part it's a lot of characters
sitting down reading from books
literally saying this is this you have
to know this for this to occur and it
feels like you're reading an instruction
manual for Pet Sematary or something so
the first half of the movie is really
bogged down in a lot of that once you
understand how things work you can tell
the filmmakers are almost freed by that
notion and make a considerably better
movie all of a sudden because they're
not as worried about setting things up
about explaining things to us potential
idiots in the audience because the first
half of the movie does kind of make you
feel like they're talking down to you
which is unfortunate I think even people
who aren't necessarily Stephen King fans
understand the Pet Sematary what it's
about what it does it's just one of
those things that horror fans know about
and it's something we we just understand
it and I feel like the film really tells
you just so much to try to make sure you
do and it's like I got it I got it the
first time you said he'd don't have to
say it again unfortunately that's what
they used the John Lithgow character for
quite often as a mouthpiece for this
exposition still though John Lithgow was
awesome in this movie he's probably my
favorite part of it
it's one of my favorite performances
from him I've seen I think he's really
terrific and excellent and he too has a
back story that that makes you sort of
feel for him and care for him and
understand how we got to this place in
life which is so unfortunate because our
lead character he just is kind of bland
and he doesn't have much to him but this
is the person we're following this is a
very condensed version of certain things
and yes there is a major change however
I don't really think it's as major as
some people made it out to be it's just
just a shift of something like it's not
like this drastic you know thing like
the the mist if you've seen the mist and
you read the mist book and you watch the
last few minutes of the mist you know
exactly what I'm talking about it's
nothing like that it's just a difference
in the character and it doesn't really
do that much I think to hinder the story
in fact here I kind of like actually
what they've done with it I think it
added a certain depth of character that
it wouldn't have had so in summary the
performances are very strong although
the lead character is just very boring
it's not necessarily Jason Clark's fault
there's just not that much to him and it
takes so long to set up the rules of Pet
Sematary to the point where you feel
like you're just reading a guide book
but once all of that's out of the way
the movie picks up considerably and I
liked the way it ended as well it had a
chilling it was good it was good and I
just wish at the beginning and you know
like the first act and the beginning the
second could have just been just so much
more compelling than it was I'm gonna
give Pet Sematary a C+ guys thank you so
much as always for watching I'm gonna
have more reviews for you very soon in a
new episode of my filmmaking journey I
have a lot of update to tell you guys
I'm really excited about that thank you
guys as always look forward to more very
soon and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]
you